[Music]
hey guys it's probably dark in here
[Music]
learning lighting actually just behind
it's bad right that's the good leg
that's look at that it's a good I'm a
genius now I'm just grabbing is this
good is it fit that's great
amazing in Seattle in some tunnel right
now doing some back seat answers tactic
de bunch of Amazon stuff hopefully we'll
get some content but Batman I've been
it's been really spotty these two days
but that's just the reality of actually
you know being see over two hundred
million dollar holding company you know
I work not an influencer by the way
influencers this worked but I run a 900
[Music]
people cuz they razz me for like hey why
don't you like do mix it up and like
[ __ ] work in 15 hours a day can't go
on a [ __ ] kite or snowboard I also
don't have those skills
alright sean has question for Sean if
have you add 10 to 20,000 in your bank
account today
[Music]
1020 million thousand fun here slip-up
thousand I would I would start a
ironically a vice of a retail flip
business because I think ten to twenty
to 150,000 in one year is very realistic
if you learned the art of the flip
buying stuff at wholesale close I've got
toys r us right now clean them out buy
their stuff put it on Amazon Marketplace
put on eBay the grind of the flip is
remarkable
you know Church sales town wide sales
thrift stores
Alibaba wholesalers liquidation sales
buying bulk buying bulk on eBay breaking
it down and reselling it on eBay
Craigslist free if you have $100 and you
go to Craigslist and go to the free
section you can probably get to ten
thousand year one if you actually
[ __ ] work you [ __ ] look like
it's work everyone's looking for the
[ __ ] secret sauce there's no [ __ ]
lazy [ __ ] juice out there
lazy juice is not real it's a pipe dream
no passive income I've got a work
we've got a question from Garrett it's a
nerdy question okay it's gone early just
opened up my third yoga studio with my
girlfriend we want leverage a voice and
wanted some advice on what direction to
take our first audio class is podcasting
Alexa skills I would go podcast I would
go I would start a yoga show and I would
make it about yoga but also the journey
of building out three studios in a short
period of time
also the dynamics of running a business
when you're boyfriend and girlfriend
your truths the answer to all your
questions are your truths the most
interesting and compelling content you
can make is your truth Batman's most
interesting content is not the photos
that he takes from videos he makes which
are remarkable he's very talented it's a
journey of how he got here like like why
did he take the job how did he see it
like does he really how does he handle
the d-roc razzing does he like it does
he hate it like what's he thinking about
what's the long-term when did he realize
he should bet on me what's going on like
how does it affect his personal life in
his early 20s being this busy like who
has he learned from besides me what how
who wins at Vayner who loses that banner
what's care really about does she really
act like that in real life you know what
have you learned why is traveling fun
what do you do when you can't film look
at like but your most interesting
content is your truth
I think we hit this the other day like
my content is boring I'm a businessman
I'm I'm in meetings 15 hours a day I've
been eating this 15 hours a day
yes I'm entertaining charismatic
increasingly handsome I get it but none
of that stuff is driving value what's
driving value is my ability to
communicate what my days about if you
can figure that out you're off to races
I mean you know successful show would be
about somebody who is being lazy yo
here's my truth I'm entitled I suck just
wanna play video games I think it's
gonna come to me naturally like you know
finding out what happens to Sally
after she realizes that after a year of
logging is the most interesting part
your truth is undefeated who are your
favorite rappers back in the day
notorious b.i.g The Fat Boys I was I was
a huge bone thugs-n-harmony fan too
short I love too short
caris one that's what stands out
1:31 yeah gary you mentioned in a recent
podcast that pokemons go is like the
front stir of today's AR world
i mean ii mean ii was the first kind of
thing that i got okay what do you think
facebook would look like it and they are
in mind that's a great thing that's a
great great question
if we're going gaming if we're gonna
gaming the facebook is you know just a
game that is being played by people for
seven to ten years like just game that
never quit you know but I think a are
has a lot of other functionality besides
gaming and so a mapping you know a
Google map or an Apple maps I think I
start up a wheeze like character could
pop up around maps that were
incentivized imagine had a map app that
was a are that was super effective got
you to where he wanted but every time
you poked it to the real world there
were things going on that were good
right so we're here at t-mobile's campus
right now imagine if we were using the
map to get to where we're going to this
meeting but it also popped like in that
Bush right there or like you know just
put it against that wall right imagine
in an AR environment didn't open that
wall it also has like $25 off your your
your a subscription or or or the
competitor you know is putting up like
you know a Verizon switch now and you
know free for a year the gamification of
our world through a utility I think is
very interesting whether that's Maps or
or other things and so what happens when
you're walking through an airport you
know utility cuz you're trying to get to
your gate but also you're being sold or
gamified along the way I think there's
clearly a huge potential for a are but I
think they are really hits its crescendo
when we go to contact lenses and not
phones when working through a voice you
know kind of like a a seamless computing
environment with you know ears your
pieces and and contacts you can really
get into some crazy [ __ ] if you're
switching literally through your voice
activation at first between AR VR and
reality that makes reality world
that's really interesting
[Music]